courtney cox
is bringing back the routine this time
with the help of ed sheeran i'm having a
ball
on sunday the actress hit up instagram
to share this video with the grammy
winner reenacting her iconic dance from
friends
[Applause]
yeah you remember the one
[Applause]
okay so that was quartz character monica
and david schwimmer as her older brother
ross slaying that choreography on the
set of dick clark's new year's rockin
eve back in 1999
season 6 episode 10 to be exact and this
this is the 56 year old friend star
nailing it
present day with ed
[Music]
not bad right but they opted out of that
big catch at the end
and went with this instead
not quite as graceful but i'm still here
for it
i hope so courtney captioned the clip
quote just some routine dancing with a
friend
adding the hashtag re-routine
naturally the post got a whole lot of
love in the comments
kaylee cuoco wrote what we're all
thinking quote
this is epic lisa kudrow gave it an all
caps
wow tan france added this is amazing
while jewelry designer jenn meyer chimed
in
asking did you just break the internet
honestly we're very lucky
of course this is hardly the first
friends themed performance from court
recently
back in february she gave us this
rendition of the sitcom's famous theme
song on the piano
and this all comes after hbo max's
long-awaited friends the reunion special
which brought the cast back together on
the old set
17 years after the show wrapped from the
first
table read of the pilot without having
met any of the others beforehand
we all felt kind of an instant chemistry
going way back
e.t recently sat down with the cast and
they opened up about their tight bond
even decades after the show first
premiered in 1994.
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something
like this